it's on to my prawn tostada wonderful
prawns for marinate them first a little
bit of garlic nice and fine
I don't worry if you can't slice thinly
just get a little grater and grate the
garlic nice and fine as well nice pinch
of chilli flakes over your prawn garlic
in salt pepper olive oil give that a
really nice little mix whilst the prawns
marinade I'm gonna knock up a salad this
is a really nice sort of light fragrant
salad radishes topped and tailed and
then into quarters
Choa tomatoes halved spring onions
sliced and seasoned and then just to
liven things up a bit of chili in there
and slice them on an angle now the
avocado cut in half give that a little
twist so you just go down and down and
down carefully with your knife turn it
around
go down and down and down and then you
take your spoon you've got your diced
avocado coming out already
now baby gem lettuce half then shred
freshly squeezed lime juice and a little
drizzle of olive oil to start as a
classic Mexican style open tour tear so
that lime complements it beautifully
lastly roughly chopped coriander and
give it a mix that is the perfect base
for a tostada the salads ready now for
the prawns and don't be afraid of
getting pan nice and hot teaspoon of
olive oil in
anything less than that sizzle when you
put that first porn in there don't put
them in keep them nice and flat make
sure you got all that marinade in there
as well watch them change color or
rapidly they'll rather cook them quicker
in a hotter pan and slower in a colder
pan the difference in taste is not to
date the prawns will take just two
minutes to cook through lime juice just
over the top nice toss them over the
line these are corn tortilla quite
robust and is the kind of base that
doesn't disintegrate hot pan in its a
dry pan so that corn tortilla goes nice
and crisp on the outside
[Music]
on a crispy shell to build them generous
in the salad that place will stay nice
and crisp
next would be prawns I like to keep the
tails in to the center and lay the round
part of the prawn on the outside and
there we have the delicious yet very
humble prawn tostada